we're going out with you Gabe we're out
the sunny beaches Saints San Diego he'd
be barn you think I'm alive yeah live in
a Trump world yeah I know how was your
girl she's good I haven't seen her in a
while had ever met her why didn't you
bring her to the fights oh she had an
event she does events on the weekends
she thinks they're advance her cool
people huh that's her job her cool
friends with Steven Soderbergh right no
really Scott you keepsake stevia soda
whatever and a lot of people are doing
lots of fancy things I'm happy for you
I really am and last night if you guys
have a chance and I like to plug him my
very dear friend Paul Mobley he's a
photographer if you go to Paul Morley
studios.com you can see some of this
work he's done a lot of people I was
Cooper of Tom Hanks a lot of people and
he came to my house and we did some
tiger belly photo shoot tonight yeah oh
cool last night at my house here and the
one he liked the best was one mean call
a liver completely naked which I was
completely unprepared for because I
thought that we were proud initially I
thought that we were gonna go to a
studio or some place that he chose and I
thought go B go B I swear to god
I'm allowing you to be in the room I
told you not to allow her I know I gave
her a shot all right so we're on your
lap stop oh stop okay you're allowed to
be in here or you want to be the cage my
love okay steel cage okay go ahead Paul
I didn't know that I thought I was gonna
be clothed and we were probably gonna do
something in like costume yeah so I
didn't know that I had to be naked and
I've I'm on my period and completely
bloated so I was like frantic my sister
and I were frantically trying to draw
ABS on me I was so desperate like what
the am I gonna do I need to get I
was completely naked you know yeah and
my belly was just poofed out all the way
and I my sister was like wait wait a
second I have a bronzer let's just try
and draw you some lines in your belly
we cheat
yeah got the job didn't work oh
what did you see what I look like
thank God he was next to me thank God I
look like Boba like I just had a yeah I
look so bad he's like hey man check this
I'll check the shutter I would look in
the thing and I would just see a big
brown ball like I looked so bad and and
I uh you know what I think I'm ready for
life change like a physical yeah you
always say that every week no no this
time it's real with the house without
the stairs instead okay right now your
whole life every your approach to
fitness is Trump's approach to politics
you say it but you have no actual agenda
no policy give me delineate for
me everything give me all right I'm
gonna say this right now okay you seem
to think that I've never worked out
before I don't think god I thought let's
cut come on take it someone again it
took sterile I know you worked out I
know it was angry but really looking I
look shredded for a year I still
have some in the house winstrol its HPP
or something no that's hga just not
that's bollocks Terry I still
took it it got real but here's what I'm
gonna do here's what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to UM I'm gonna eat better someone
takes some carbs out of my diet and all
sugars yeah and I'm going to go to my
gym the boxing gym that I used to go to
I'm gonna do my thing and I'm gonna go
there once a day each day it's gonna be
different one day I'm gonna do purely
treadmill because you have to trick your
body muscle confusion what's the
confusion yeah and then the next day I
cuz you don't understand that many years
ago Abby got me a Hollywood trainer or
you know a personal trainer oh yeah and
I and I spent thousands and thousands of
dollars and I met with him every other
day and I saw I know the rhythm and roll
of the gym life my my issue with you
and I already know where it fails for
you know is that the you go so hardcore
that it's not a sustainable lifestyle
you have
go according to something that you feel
you can carry out for the rest of your
life so it's like no you shouldn't work
out even a small or not eat sashimi oh
you get a dick you get addicted to work
it's not that he goes so extreme for
three weeks no no only eat sashimi for
years you know you don't remember
do you don't know I swear to God ask Ike
Barinholtz because when MADtv got
canceled I was pretty fat mm-hmm and
then a couple years later hadn't seen me
and I had a birthday party at booked
with Pepco my favorite yeah yeah no
restaurant but Spaghetti Factory yeah my
second and I um he saw him and he goes
dude what the I mean I transformed
myself and then I that was two years of
working out and eating really good damn
and that's because I used to go I mean I
just do ridiculous things like only eat
at Whole Foods so I would just get
sashimi and there are vegetable rolls
was all vegetables and drink that
coconut naked coconut water right and
that's it every meal yeah but your life
I'm just saying I'm all or nothing so
I'm at a point now where I might be done
with destiny I mean I'm not kidding you
I'm you love it you're good at it I
don't know listen to me right now man I
hit a pot the only way I can change
anything is if I hit a bottom and it's
sad to say but I have to look I have to
be able to look in a crystal ball and go
oh my god my life is gonna go nowhere or
this is not gonna end up good for you
and then my and then I just force myself
to change that's I've been that like
that with drugs
I've been done that with the way I've
done that with video games I've done
with all kinds of stuff you guys have a
witnessed it because it takes I can I
can take a lot of spiritual rape what I
mean by that is is that I can I can
really hold in a lot of like you know
the depression and anger and all that
stuff and being beaten down I can I
could withstand it but there comes a
breaking point and right now I'm about
to have a breaking point especially with
destiny you know it's just like
it's getting out of hand I'm not gonna
stop I'm not there yet
late it's calming what would trigger it
um I think a couple of more months of
not working on something like because
you know this year I was lucky I had
some things I was doing I loved I would
do but I don't know if Love's gonna be
here for me next year I don't know a lot
of things so you know those things have
to go away for me to motivate to change
so then when I change I'm going to go to
more a meetings I want to eat better and
work better and be better to my lady but
I have to UM I have to be battered it
battered to the point where I do it
because for me pain and suffering is the
biggest motivator so where people go my
life isn't working out I'm depressed I
want to kill myself I go good sit on it
because if you don't change you're good
that's it and I know myself I know I'm
going to change
[Music]